a long time but I also know her previous
boyfriends 20 hence cliff right
we love names here by the way you see
your butthole huh go back to the right
answer yeah that's the thing I've heard
it's not it's a great vibe you asked for
no I don't ask for it it just happened
you know you do have a look if I were a
guy I'd probably go for [ __ ] what is
it you look like yeah that's what it is
yeah it's like you you look like you I
should violate you because pure and
innocent looking that would probably go
for the grossest thing first yeah you
know it just cheeks probably look like
marshmallows yeah you know me like like
tall boots and white and round right
yeah
the first weekend that I met you the
first thing she said to me she said he
want to see my boobs and she just showed
me yeah like that that was our bonding
moment I was like oh I like this girl
that must have been because I liked your
boobs I just wanted to see yours
probably but yeah I never showed you
mine you show me yours it was a
one-sided rapport there one of my
favorite Bobby memories is when I was at
the Comedy Store and you're upstairs by
the old office with Russell Brand and I
walked in the room and like got scared
and walked out and then afterwards like
why didn't you come over I would have
introduced at him and then you told me
that I had the social skills of an 18th
century goes Russell I think he said I
think no it was a ghost no Russell
because Russell what we're all so Brown
would do is he would like candles around
in a room and have to do I'm not kidding
you
one-hour meditations before he did this
for 2 min the spot you know which is
that's how he does him that's fine
everyone has their own ritual right but
when you came in and out right it took
him out of his life
you know meditation right and so he saw
something white in his peripheral vision
right and he thought it was a ghost and
I had to convince him that it was a
bastard
did you ever end up meeting him no yeah
you [ __ ] up it's fine you're a good
person and then I also love one note I
want to get back into your butthole so
when they don't ask to eat your butthole
and they just dive right in I don't say
no or you like it why would I say no and
no I okay I don't like it I don't have
like a strong opinion on it my thoughts
like hey we're at this point where we're
both doing these things like not you
know we're naked in a bed together like
just do whatever yeah you did you make
you pretend you like like you see no I
don't really pretend I like anything
over the years I feel like I'm starting
to realize I'm just like I lie there and
just whatever happens what do they
penetrate you do feel things or you know
my my oh yeah Morrissey like you do a
sexual I mean you're into it right yeah
I guess okay I don't know I'm just like
yeah it's sex stuff is happening now
I guess sex stuff is happening again sex
stuff is happening
[Music]